hello everyone thanks for joining me in
this video today I'd like to go over
ways to practice trills things to keep
in mind and also share with you an
exercise that will allow you to practice
chills in a concentrated manner in the
context of some pretty harmonies as well
now if you'd like to follow along with
the sheet music you can download it for
free from my website something to keep
in mind is that there are many many
different types of trills in different
lengths different dynamics different
Tambor's depending on the context of the
music here are some examples
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
you
you
[Music]
one of the things that really helps me
when learning a trill is to actually
write it out as if it wasn't a trill at
all now in practice we're not going to
be playing these trills in such a
measured way but this definitely helps
us visualize the notes that go into the
trill so here I want to put in a little
ornament
so let's actually write that out so if
we slow it way down you can find out the
note value that we're gonna use to write
it out so these will be 32nd note
triplets so the main reason I do this is
because when I see the notes written out
visually it helps me attend to every
single note of the trill similarly when
you have a long trill maybe you want to
actually plan it out just to see how it
feels with triplets or groups of four
groups of five however you want to
organize it so for example let's take
this trill instead of just treating it
as one long held note with a trill let's
break it up so this is my eighth note
pulse the note values will be in groups
of six per eighth note so even if we're
going to abandon this framework when
we're actually playing the trill it
helps to sort of form your trill in the
first place another thing to keep in
mind is fingering now there are many
different types of trills so there are
many different types of fingerings but
let's go over just a few of them I think
the most commonly used fingers for
trills our fingers one two and three so
one and three which is actually my least
favorite fingering and we'll get back to
why two three and one three one two one
alternating
so depending on the context sometimes I
need that sort of power where I need to
be alternating between fingers but
sometimes I don't and sometimes I can't
maybe it's a trill underneath the left
hand or vice versa then I don't have
that space to be changing around so
beyond these three fingers I also really
like fingers to four also three four and
if I need a little more sound I'll use
four to three to also 3/5 and 4/5 now
that's a little weak anyway those
fingerings also apply to the left hand
but in Reverse so now let's move on to
talking a little bit about the mechanics
of playing the trills so we're going
back and forth between two notes or two
sets of notes so let's imagine we have a
balance point in the middle and we have
a firm object here which our fingers
will be balancing on and we're gonna go
back and forth like this so this motion
to me represents the motion that we have
to keep in mind for a trill so it's more
than just going back and forth between
two notes and hitting those two notes
it's this sort of teeter-totter motion
and that's where you can get the speed
and to keep this very fast and very
consistent the amount of distance your
fingers go from playing the keys and
going back up based on this motion
should always be consistent and that
will also translate into a consistent
and controlled sound now when we're
practicing we can keep this in mind and
pay close attention to how far our
fingers are moving up from the keys and
how in sync the two fingers are with
each other
so kind of similar to writing out the
notes of the trill just visualizing this
lever and this middle point when I'm
playing a trill helps me because I'm
visualizing this movement and this sense
of balance that centers my trills now
let's go back to this trill and we're
going to be building up in speed let's
first start with groups of two
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
approximately some more times than not
it's much more reliable to be using the
fingers rather than the wrists because
it's very easy to try and play all kinds
of trills with just this wrist motion
because you kind of just need to shake
but you'll find that in most cases doing
a trill like this will give you so much
control in sound and clarity but that
being said there are some instances that
you probably are better off using this
wrist rotation type of trill
all right so here is an exercise I came
up with to practice drills in a somewhat
isolated manner while also sort of
working on transposition as well so here
are the notes we're going to be trilling
on this see
so now we can alter this in many ways we
can use different fingerings to for
[Music]
let's increase the volume and do four to
three to
we can also use this to practice
transitioning from one trill to the next
and we're going to be changing the
fingerings to do so but depending on if
we're going from a white key to a white
key or white key to black black to black
etc it'll change just as an example for
a fingering for such transition let's go
from C to F and we'll start with 1 & 2
and when we go to the F will first start
with 3 but we will do 3 4 to 3 and then
we're in a prime position to use 2 & 3
so we can also modify this to play
shorter trills so we're going to take
this note and turn it into triplets and
we're going to be adding 3 notes to the
main note starting from the top now in
order to go through all the different
fingerings we're going to be changing
from 2 1 3 1 3 2 for our first set and
then 2 4 3 4 3 5 for our next set 4 5 3
5 3 4 for the next set and for the final
set 2 4 2 3 1 3 and we're back to the
beginning
so hopefully you can take this and
modify it to your liking depending on
the type of trill that you'd like to
work on anyway I hope you found that
helpful thanks again for joining me in
this video and I'll see you in the next
one thanks
[Music]